florence bouquet vice-présidente du
collectif inter blog on soit florence
bouquet merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous faites partie de ces
collectifs qui ont déposé des plaintes
notamment sur les masques aujourd'hui
cette ouverture d' enquête c'est un bon
début pour vous oui tout à fait parce
qu'on voulait se faire entendre et
mettre à jour le manquement qu'il y a eu
tout au long de cette gestion du coup
vide et c'était important qu'on
[Musique]
représentait entendu aujourd'hui quels
sont les principaux griefs justement
vous reprocher au gouvernement dans la
gestion de cette crise qu'est ce qui
justifie justement qu'elle est obligée
de répondre de ses fautes notamment dont
ceux qu'on se positionne par rapport aux
masques ffp2 parce qu'au bloc opératoire
il ya une partie de l'équipe
c'est à dire l'équipe anesthésie qui
portent des masques ffp2 et l'équipe
george j call qui en est dépourvu sur
beaucoup d'établissements donc c'est mon
ami m on a mandaté m division qui a
écouté nos d'élégance et qui a mis les
établissements en demeure de nous
fournir à l'équipe chirurgicale des
masques et sp2 il ya clairement eu
préjudice racontez-nous justement cette
époque parce que souvent quand on porte
plainte c'est qu'il ya clairement un
préjudice de nombreux soignants on
imagine son sont tombés malades
cette époque là bien sûr il ya des
soignants qui ont été contaminés est le
fait surtout que alors comme on dit
c'est michel jouets qu'ils aient ça
l'absence de preuve n'est pas preuve de
l'absence
on a pas de consensus scientifique qui
va dire que le virus est présent dans
les fumées chirurgicale mais toujours
est il que il y à des risques pour le
personnel et de l'instant où il ya des
risques les établissements se doivent
d'après le code du travail de de fournir
des précautions pour prévenir ces
risques c'est d'assurer la sécurité des
soignants donc c'était important de tous
les soignants sont équipés en salle de
masque chirurgical clairement l'anc est
un vice
les chefs de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui domicile et blessures
involontaires de non-assistance à
personnes en péril les mots sont forts
d'ailleurs le procureur de la république
a précisé qu'il n'était pas là pour
définir des responsabilités politiques
ou administratives mais bel et bien pour
mettre à jour des infractions pénales
des décideurs nationaux pour vous
clairement un ministre
aujourd'hui doit être considérée comme
pénalement responsable facettes
face à cette justement pénurie de
masques alors je pense que au vu de ce
qui a été dit par rapport à la
gouvernance où il ya eu un peu tout a
été dit et le au contraire également je
pense qu'ils doivent aussi assumer une
part de responsabilité effectivement
vous pardonnez moi je vous ai coupés
dans je vous en prie non je disais ma
part de responsabilité mais mais c'est
vrai que cette crise a révélé beaucoup
de lourdeur de l'administration
française c'est ce qui est vraiment
ressorti à différents étages
est ce que ce n'est pas juste je me fais
volontairement l'avocat du diable mais
mais voilà de poursuivre une seule
personne un ministre qui finalement est
dans un système très lourd et lent doux
c'est pas les ministres ainsi des
établissements de santé qui ont été
visés par cette plainte
les ministres sont aussi visés en
l'occurrence pour leur mauvaise gestion
de la crise
finalement oui surtout au malawi sur sur
d'autres plaintes effectivement il ya eu
80 plein qui me semble au total ont été
déposés clairement qu'attendez-vous de
de cette enquête aujourd'hui nous ce
qu'on voudrait faire c'est les faire
remonter toutes les toute la défaillance
qui a eu par rapport à notre gouvernance
en fait on a un système d' entité
décisionnel qui a dit qui a dit et qui a
fait aussi un peu n'importe quoi est ce
qu'on concernant le matériel on l'a bien
vu avec donc notamment les les masses
l'eau gèle les sur blues qu'est-ce qu'on
a eu d'autres également on a eu
par rapport au respirateur aussi il ya
eu d énormément de deux respirateurs qui
ont été commandés et qui nous en fait
n'était pas du tout adaptée pour le les
patients à la prise en charge des
patients qu'on vide il ya eu toutes ces
transport de patients c'est ça a été
fait par les hélicoptères les comment le
le porte hélicoptères tonnerre tout cela
engendrait beaucoup de frais et c'était
pas en fait justifiée il y avait des
établissements privés qui étaient
beaucoup plus près que les 800
kilomètres qui ont été nécessaires pour
transférer des patients de de mulhouse à
toulouse et je pense que voilà il ya une
gestion qui a été désastreuse alors
aujourd'hui un gala merkel emmanuel
macron presse l'union européenne de se
préparer une prochaine pandémie
c'est ce qu'on vient d'apprendre ils ont
adressé une lettre à l'union européenne
estimant que l'union européenne n'avait
pas été à la hauteur face au co vide
19 il évoque éventuellement une
prochaine pandémie hypothétique vous
êtes en accord avec ça parce que au-delà
de la france l'europe n'a pas su faire
face selon vous également oui pour
beaucoup de choses c'est vrai qu'on a on
affirmer les usines on les a transférés
en chine un peu entendu partout et la
problématique c'est qu'on n'est plus en
capacité d'avoir rapidement du matériel
heureusement qu'il ya eu le système d
qui s'est mis en place où les personnels
soignants ont posté on y ont fait appel
que ce soit aux entreprises de btp au
parti marie il ya eu une vraie cohésion
de la part de l'ensemble du public soit
de nos gouvernants pour pour se
substituer justement à ce défaut de
cette défaillance en tout même au niveau
humain on l'a déjà vu les ils ont
rappelé des élèves infirmiers qui ne
sont pas formés alors qu'elle a dans la
réserve sanitaire il y a à peu près 4000
donc pour moi je suis inscrite à 4000
personnel soignant et qui ont pas du
tout étaient dispatchés sur les les
endroits où il y avait nécessité d'avoir
des personnes qui étaient formés en plus
lettres des élèves qui sont pas formés
ces missiles merci beaucoup florence
bouquet vice-présidente du collectif
inter bloc d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france